Ready for this one?
SCP-682 vs SCP-835 is one of the most horrifying
SCP-682 cross tests we have logged to date!
That’s right!
We have paired the Hard to Destroy Reptile
with the disgusting nightmare known as SCP-835,
a giant carnivorous coral polyp made from
living human matter!
When SCP-835 was released, the infectious
abomination pulled SCP-682 into its massive
gullet, dragging it down for a slow and painful
digestion, surrounded by the intense pressure
and screaming human faces of the beast’s
fleshy throat.
What was eventually ejected was little more
than SCP-682’s skeleton.
However, over time this skeleton regenerated
into a horrific hybrid of SCP-682 and SCP-835:
Covered in sticky tentacles, human faces spewing
acid, and infectious spores that could turn
others into monsters.
It breached containment and killed many.
The survivors had to be terminated to avoid
SCP-835 contamination spreading further.